so last year mortgage rates moved up to
7% prices gave just a little bit
nationally and I think there was a
feeling that
okay we've seen the worst of the
affordability and then we came into this
year and National prices moved up more
we set a new uh all-time high this
summer and then rates went even higher
to 8% so as we are doing this call right
now this is the worst of affordability
in like 35
years all right guys bang bang I've got
Lance here with me Lance housing
affordability is the worst that's been
in 40 years what exactly is going on and
why is housing become so untouchable for
so many Americans yeah housing
affordability is really getting
pressurized right now and it's been
deteriorating not just you know the past
few months but the past few years and
the speed that this has happened this is
the fastest deterioration in housing
affordability ever and the actual level
of housing affordability now is it
lows three decade lows right we are not
that far off from when mortgage rates
affordability wise we're not that far
off from when mortgage rates were 18% in
the early 80s and that's because house
prices relative to incomes are just so
stretched right now
and so when you look at the numbers for
somebody who would go out and get a
mortgage today their payment for the
typical buyer is
120% more than somebody who bought at
the uh two and a half years ago during
the pandemic frenzy and so somebody
could have bought during the height of
the pandemic frenzy uh in 2021 they
could have bought two homes and had the
same monthly payment a somebody buying
one home today the the speed that we've
deteriorated is just historic and so
what's happened here is there's two
things one during the pandemic we had a
historic overheating on the price side
so National house prices from March
2020 to June 2022 went up about 44%
nationally some markets like Austin and
Boise yeah it was close to 70% it was
just a historic frenzy and then
following that overheating on prices the
FED went into the fastest rate hiking
cycle in four decades and so mortgage
rates went from the lowest all time in
January
2021 of
2.65% and then slowly by the end of 2021
went up to three but then entering
2022 they went from 3% to 4% to 5 5% to
6% to 7% by November
2022 and then now they've ticked up a
little higher we're now this as of today
going into this call we are sitting at
the highest average 30y or fixed
mortgage rate of
8.03 for the mortgage News Daily that's
the highest since late 2000 so mortgage
rates have just cooked and we've went
from a two something handle to an 8-s
something handle and affordability has
just got pressurized across the country
and that mortgage rate move that's for
everybody everybody across the country
has seen that deterioration on the right
on the right side now when we talk about
housing affordability obviously people
immediately think of home prices and if
prices are going up and the cost of
capital is going up that is a major
factor you mentioned pay the payments
that people receive their income how
does that play into this calculation and
is it something where if housing prices
and the cost of capital stayed where it
was but all of a sudden everyone got a
you know 100% pay raise then
affordability would go down and and so
there's almost like two sides to the
equation or is it really the only
solution here is we have to get housing
prices to go back down the cost of
capital to go back down to make this
something that's more tenable for the
average American yeah so housing
affordability is three numbers it's
incomes it's prices and its rates and so
two of the levers have worked at rapid
speed against buyers and that's prices
and rates and incomes just can't move at
the rate that those two did during the
pandemic um and so heading forward to
relax
affordability you would need either
rates to come down or income growth to
exceed house price growth or or you know
you could actually have house prices
fall too that's another way to improve
it but incomes either need to rise
prices fall or rates rise or the
relative speed of incomes outpace the
other two that would improve
affordability the problem is
historically
speaking deteriorations in affordability
happen much faster than improvements in
affordability it usually takes a long
time to play out and housing does move
slowly but the trend the past three
years has been deterioration and we
haven't seen an an affordability
Improvement and to go back
uh you know at the when we entered the
pandemic on a historical basis that was
one of the most affordable housing
markets ever for a new buyer was
2020 and uh even though prices the
previous decade had went up a lot rates
were still kind of low and prices
relative to every or incomes relative to
everything uh you know was fairly solid
but now we're at the opposite end of the
spectrum so we've went from one of the
most affordable housing markets three
years ago to one of the most
unaffordable aable in just 3 years now
let's talk about interest rates
obviously the Federal Reserve in
November of 2021 they were like oh boy
things have gotten hot around here uh we
want to destroy demand was a phrase that
they continued to use over and over
again uh as they began to hike interest
rates they definitely destroyed
investment demand in stocks in
cryptocurrency uh in Commodities Etc
housing wasn't a big part of that
conversation initially now talking about
housing affordability and so how much
weight does the fed put on housing
affordability when it's making some of
these interest rate decisions they claim
not to care about the stock market or or
or some of these other investment
classes do they actually incorporate
housing affordability when they decide
should they raise interest rates or
should they not yeah so last year a
series of papers came out from the fed
and we've started to see just how
concerned they've been with housing so
the first paper showed that of the price
appreciation during the pandemic 60% of
it was uh could be attributed to the
work from home effect and the demand for
more housing space and so how that works
is it's not just people relocating but
it's also the fact that people who stay
in these markets like New York San
Francisco and all these places they want
more space because they're at home more
right so that elevated demand for space
happened Nationwide and that helped to
overheat price
that's the first paper the second paper
is a paper that found and and that first
one is from the S Francisco fed if you
want to Google it the second paper found
that during the pandemic housing demand
increased so fast that Supply would have
needed to move up
300% to match the elevated housing
demand that occurred during the pandemic
and that just wasn't possible so really
what happened during the pandemic is
that the elevation and housing demand
could never get met there was just never
enough supply for it to get met and so
what happens when the actual market
demand exceeds the supply price
overheating and that's what happened
during the pandemic and the third paper
and this one might be the most
interesting is that this rapid increase
in housing wealth which occurred you
know 45% move up in prices in under 24
months
and a lot of that went to the already
wealthiest segment of the population
those over 50 what it created was a
tremendous wealth effect and the the FED
calculates the the board of fed
Governors calculates that onethird of
all non-housing inflation was caused by
the Boom in
housing so that's both from the wealth
effect and that's from the Boom in the
housing uh seor
and so and you could see this when the
FED started to rate hike Neil kashari
would go out and talk about how you know
there's so much home equity and that was
a concern and so I think one of the
reasons that the FED went into the rate
hikes at the speed that it did wasn't
that it necessarily was concerned that
inflation was going to rip even faster
like the you know it was already out of
the gate and I think they knew it was
kind of going to decelerate
but I think one of the reasons they went
into the rate hik so aggressively so
early is that they knew that that would
push the long-term tale of the market
the 10year treasury 30-year fixed
mortgage rates up really fast and so
what happened is because mortgage rates
went from 3% to
7% within six seven months last year
nobody did home equity uh nobody was
tapping into home equity nobody was
doing the cash there was fewer of the
Cash out refinance es because one of the
fed's fears was that what because home
prices had went up so fast if people
were grabbing that Equity that could
have triggered even more growth in
consumer demand and inflation and so
they've kind of taken that out of
they've taken that off the table for a
bid because mortgage rates have went up
so fast I mean really the only way
you're doing a cash out refi at 7% giv
up your 3% mortgage rate four for a
seven is if you're in financial distress
you're not doing it because you know you
want to remodel your kitchen you want to
go buy an inground pool uh but had they
not rate rate hiked as fast as they did
let's say they only got you know
mortgage rates up to four or five by the
end of last year there would have been
even more of that cash out reive so I do
think that home prices and the
aggressiveness that they moved up during
the pandemic really mattered for the FED
now in terms of their fed goals um um
you know the most important is rents and
we are seeing a deceleration on the
multif family side there's a lot of
Supply coming in the single family uh
rental side has stayed a little stronger
um now in terms of home prices they've
been a bit resilient nationally and I
think the fed you know would have
probably liked home prices to come down
a bit more uh but I think based on
comments that the Richmond fed made fed
president made three weeks ago they're
kind of saying okay yeah home prices
haven't come down more but it's probably
because of secular shift in the economy
where people just want more housing now
uh because we've gone to a world where
we're less in the office more at home
people want more space And so there's
kind of a you know a trade-off where
we're kind of accepting that home prices
are probably going to be a little more
elevated in this environment but what he
did say is that okay okay if we're in an
environment where there's more secular
demand for housing and so prices are
going to stay higher there then on a
relative basis prices got to give up
somewhere else in the economy and uh you
know I I think the place that that's
happening obviously is commercial real
estate now when we go and we look at
some of these specific markets uh there
really is kind of a tale of two right um
and what you've broken down multiple
times on Twitter and and uh in the email
is this idea that Austin Texas is down
10% from September 2022 to September
2023 and they seem to be one of the
worst uh kind of uh recipients of a lot
of this problem but then there's places
like Hartford and uh New Haven
Connecticut and many others that are
actually up in terms of home prices in
that same time period And so when you
look at the United States what is
driving certain markets down but at the
same time certain markets are going up
is there a way to kind of understand
this bifurcation uh in terms of why
different markets are responding in a
different way to the same exact interest
rate uh hikes today's episode is brought
to you by trust and will I've gone
through a number of different changes in
my life over the last few years I got
married I had a kid and I had to start
thinking about how could I ensure that
my wife and my child would be okay if
anything ever happened to me that's
where trust wills and estate planning
come into play now most people what they
do is they get introduced to a friend an
uncle or someone in their local
community it tends to be someone who's
really expensive a lawyer an accountant
or somebody who does Estate Planning and
they just simply are using a one-size
fits-all template and just telling you
pay me thousands of dollars and I'll use
the same thing for you as the guy down
the street but that's not what trust and
will does they have a trusted online
estate planning product that starts as
low as
$159 which allows you to now protect
your legacy from the comfort of your own
home leverage their excellent customer
support available via phone email or
chat they have thousands of f- star
reviews VI and a rating of excellent on
trust pilot it takes most people 20 to
30 minutes to complete their estate plan
with trust and will and not only that
but if you go to trustand will.com pomp
you'll get 10% off plus you'll get free
shipping of all your estate planning
documents so go to trustand will.com
Pomp and make sure you get an estate
plan in place whether it's for you or
one of your loved ones having a trust
Andor a will can literally be the
difference between someone being taken
care of and someone not go check them
out today at trustand will.com pomp yeah
so during the pandemic homes across the
country with not a lot of exceptions
boomed right prices ripped everywhere
now there were the markets that ripped
even harder places like Austin Boise
that really saw the work from home
effect a lot of people with California
money coming in New York money and the
thing is uh about uh California money
and even to some degree New York money
is that uh it it you know it's kind of
honey badger money it just doesn't care
and so they you know and if and if your
marginal buyer in your Market is
California money and New York money
prices are probably going to rip um and
so that's what happened in those markets
and they kind of got over their skis um
and so when mortgage rat spiked last
year because prices in those markets
which have went up 70% two years they
were already getting to the point where
it was pricing out a lot of locals right
but then once mortgage rate spiked and
you kind of took away the
affordability uh lure from some of these
places like New York and California plus
some offices were reopening people were
kind of rethinking this abrupt lifestyle
uh shift that set those markets up for
perfect uh correction modes or like a
perfect storm for a correction mode and
you know the the corrections there
haven't been like too too intense uh
according to most of the numbers I look
at Zillow or or Austin from the peak is
down somewhere between 12 and 15%
Boise's down like 10 to 12% so they've
given up you know the tops of the pan uh
pandemic but still up you know 40
something percent from the start of the
pandemic so anyone who bought in those
markets before the pandemic or early you
know they're still very much in the
green
now what we have seen is that despite
mortgage rates moving from 3 4 5 6 78
there are some markets across the
country that are still up 10%
year-over-year and a lot of those are in
Connecticut and a lot of those are in
New Jersey and uh Midwestern markets and
I what's going on I believe is that a
lot of people who are maybe in the New
York Market are starting to realize you
know what work from home isn't probably
going to be 100% I probably need to be
close but they're also realizing hey I
only need to go in one two three days
and so it's creating a bit of more of a
dut effect around the greater New York
Market where Connecticut and New Jersey
are getting hotter and as people kind of
Chase relative affordability and so
that's pushed those markets up despite
mortgage rates being close to eight in
the midwest it's uh a bit of a different
story what it is there is that if you
look at the numbers across the country
country it's very hard to cash flow in a
lot of Western markets and a lot of even
Southern markets now because prices have
went up so high so fast and so if you're
the institutional investors or Mom and
Pop investors who want to buy homes it
it just doesn't make a lot of sense in
San Francisco and so right now for every
one investor buying in San Francisco
there's two selling so they're net
sellers in a lot of these Western
markets but in the midwest you can still
go byy single family homes at the bottom
third of the market the cash flow so
people are still buying these homes the
cash flow investors are still pushing
into the market and prices are still
moving up now when we look at uh some of
the markets that it's really bad either
home prices are uh going down or uh the
mortgage rates are creating so much pain
that Builders now are stepping in and
saying hey wait a second maybe we can
actually provide a solution uh you wrote
a piece recently that said lenar is
basically offering a fixed 4.75%
mortgage rate and so if mortgage rates
are at 78% how is lenar offering you
know something that's closer to four and
a half or five percent yeah so a lot of
these Builders during the pandemic while
they were all crying about Supply chains
and not being able to find workers there
was also the fact that their profit
margins hit the highest ever during the
pandemic and so their margins were huge
so when mortgage rate spiked last year
and sales started to Crater and I'm
talking sales not prices when sales
began to Crater once Builders had kind
of worked through their backlogs a
little bit and made sure that you know
the cancellations weren't going to be
too high from the people they had
already sold to what they started to do
is they took those margins and started
slashing them and they took that money
and did things like um mortgage rate buy
Downs so buying down somebody's rate
often it's you know like a 32 one buy
down where your first year is like a
four your next year is a 5% then it's 6%
and then maybe it gets to seven and
that's your term rate um and then you
know some of them are even you know way
way further out than just the
321s and they also did things like money
at close uh uh and and things like that
or just outright price Cuts in the
Casale like KB Homes but they had the
margins to play with and once they did
that they were able to get sales going
again and heading into this year uh you
know the first several months of the
year as the market started to stabilize
a bit uh Builders saw new home sales
really move up uh fairly quickly now
what's started to happen since then is
that mortgage rates have went up higher
now we're testing 8% and we're starting
to see the market demand is starting to
crack more and my assumption is that I
think there's going to be more downward
pressure on home builders margins
heading forward um and they will
probably have to do other types of
incentives and they're just going to
have to you know be clever now one very
big divide that's happening in housing
is that the big publicly traded Builders
who are like really close with uh
lenders are doing more of the
incentives the smaller private builders
who don't have the connections with the
lenders as much maybe don't have the
margins of the big boys they're hurting
a little more um some of them relative
to some of the bigger Builders now all
of this keep in mind varies
substantially by market and even
sometimes Community by Community basis
and there are some new home markets
where they've seen very little
Corrections KB Homes CEO told me that
you know the Inland Empire uh area out
in California which is an area where a
lot of people who are in La who are
seeking affordability goto they haven't
really seen much adjustment had to make
much adjustments there at all but a
market like Denver where resale to new
home to resale prices were got up to 30%
during the height of the pandemic and so
what that means is KB Homes usually but
on a zip code level charges prices their
homes new homes 15% higher than existing
prices there's a premium to buy a new
home during the pandemic because they
could charge whatever the hell they
wanted it got up to 30% in that market
for new home builders so in Denver in
particular the new Home Market has had
to seen more of a correction and they're
more of a slump just because their
prices got over their skis and once
mortgage rate spiked they had to you
know do some uh affordability
adjustments Where Do We Go From Here
Right obviously housing affordability is
is uh the worst that it's been in
decades um people still want and need to
buy a home um there's a complexities
with the monetary policy there's
complexities with uh construction and
Supply chains that we kind of are now
getting to the other side of um how do
you see this working out and is there a
world where we can return back to uh
housing being affordable in the United
States or is this kind of a new normal
that we should expect to persist for you
know the coming years yeah I I think
what's probably true is that we are
going to be in a place where on a
historical basis affordability is
probably deteriorated for housing uh
housing historically speaking does when
it moves into these bands uh whether
it's you know the more affordable Market
or the less affordable Market it usually
stays for a while and it takes a while
to kind of play out the last time that
we got here into this uh this band of
really deterior at affordability was
0506 and the way we got out of it is
that uh the fed and uh the economy made
people poor that's one wages uh and what
happened is prices crashed there was
GFC um and uh that that obviously is not
ideal we would I don't think we'd like
to replay GFC and you know this time the
lever down on price prices isn't quite
there like it was last time where you
had you know a huge amount of inventory
on the market you had all these terrible
mortgage products the subprime crisis um
but I think what I'm keeping an eye on
is a couple things uh for affordability
is I'm keeping an eye on one how does
this rate cycle play out if we go into a
recession there's probably a good chance
that mortgage rates come down a bit and
that would of course improve
affordability that's one uh two some
markets are probably still at risk of
Correction mode um and it's possible
that markets that have avoided
correction could still slide into the
correction uh if you are a resi Club
Premium subscriber uh I track this data
for you but what we're starting to see
is markets like San Antonio and New
Orleans have really softened although
they held up a bit stable last year as
mortgage rates started to go up so it
it's possible we could be in a period
where there's some rolling Corrections
where last year Austin and Boise and
Phoenix and Reno all took a hit and then
this year you know Phoenix kind of
stabilized Las Vegas and Reno a bit too
and then you know Austin's still taking
a they're still very much in correction
mode but now places like San Antonio and
New Orleans are kind of joining in uh
with Austin and kind of giving a bit
more on price so I'm keeping an eye on
one the macro side of the economy and
how long does the labor market hold
strong and then that has huge
implications for mortgage rates and then
two I'm watching the market
fundamentals uh down to the inventory
active listing level to kind of see if
more markets are at risk of
Corrections now you mentioned resi club
uh I think it's no secret I think that
you are the number one residential real
estate uh journalist in the country
you've been on uh this show before um
and we decided to go and do something
about the problem um and uh uh we've
both together launched resi Club talk a
little bit about what that business is
what what is the product and kind of
what your vision uh for resi Club is
over the coming years yeah I think uh
both of us kind of were in agreement
that this issue is you know it's one of
the biggest issues in the country not
just from a financial economy side uh
but just a a a country side uh you know
it's the fact that you know so many
people who are doing all of the right
things in their life they're struggling
to get into home ownership and this
issue is going to be prolonged for a bit
and so what we've done is we've created
resi club which is not only uh tracking
housing affordability what's going on on
the supply side uh you know all the
movements and mortgage rates but it's
also really getting down to you know the
what's actually happening in these
individual markets with the housing
analytics and some of it's creative that
we build you know a lot of real estate
agents like to say that anything with
six months of inventory or less is a
sell's market well here's the thing home
prices in Austin last year started to
Crater uh you know there was a flash C
when supplies uh when months of Supply
was only at two months that two months
of Supply should tell you that that
market is red hot but it wasn't now our
data flagged it because we watch
absorption and the speed of inventory
change and so we knew that Austin had
moved into correction mode right out of
the gate and so really great housing
analytics but we're also talking to the
biggest players in the country you know
IAL talk to KB CEO uh uh KB Home CEO uh
frequently uh and other builders to kind
of get a PLL some what's happening there
uh we talked to a lot of the
institutional home buyers uh I have a c
interview uh coming out this weekend
with amher coo he owns 44,000 homes in
the US his company this guy has an
incredible pulse on what's happening in
the housing market and the reason he
does
and the reason he has so much data and
has tracked every home in the country
every home in the country for 25 years
is that you know his neck's on the line
uh you know he has to know what's going
on in the market in all of these places
and so I think what resi club is doing
is we're really just shining a light on
what's actually happening in the housing
market I think if you read a lot of
these headlines you know some of them
will talk about how you know you know
housing was doing so bad last year uh
and then this year talking about how
home prices are up so much but the truth
be told is if you're in one of these
markets that doesn't fit into that
bucket you're going to be confused
you're like what the hell is going on
reading this headlines but I think if
you read resi Club you're going to be
like okay I understand I have a I have a
sense of what's going on in the market I
understand that the very top of the
market nationally is much cooler while
the bottom of the market uh is much
warmer and the reason being when
mortgage rates Spike people just shift
their expectations and we'll be like you
know what maybe I don't need that home
I'll do this type of home so it pushes
competition down um those are the types
of things that we bring to the table now
one other aspect that I'm very excited
about and uh people who have listened to
uh this show for a long time will know
uh there's very few things that when
they are put out into the world I
immediately stop and go read or or
listen to uh every single day when uh
the next article comes out I stop
everything and go and read it and I
think it is to your point probably one
of the biggest problems facing America
right now right you have 330 million
people in our country a good portion of
them don't own homes but would like to
and they can't afford it and so how do
we go ahead and we change that um first
you got to understand the problem a key
part of understanding the problem yes
there are the the Articles and to that
but you have a bunch of data that you
have your fingertips some of that you
are actually sharing with uh subscribers
to resi Club in terms of these inventory
trackers and things like that so maybe
talk a little bit about the data that
you have and then also the access to
individuals and and some of the
exclusive interviews and and things that
people just won't be able to find
anywhere else or or get access to
anywhere else this episode is brought to
you by aradine they are a brand new
startup led by a number of Silicon
Valley Legends who just raised $81
million to build the future of Internet
infrastructure your probably wondering
what that means let me explain there are
numerous new disruptive technologies
that are being adopted simultaneously
from blockchain to artificial
intelligence to zero knowledge
Technologies in order to ensure that
these Technologies thrive in this new
world we need new infrastructure and
that is where arine comes in they just
launched their first product line called
Tera flux which is a Bitcoin miner
powered by the world's first 4 nanometer
silicon chip technology these air cooled
singlephase and dual phase emerging
cooling minor have unrivaled speed and
efficiency theyve Superior uptime and
they leverage a brand new innovation
called Energy tune that allows minor to
dynamically adjust the energy
consumption and Bitcoin hash rate based
on demand response needs of the
electrical grids aradine is an ambitious
company working on hard problems I'm
really impressed with them and if you
want to check out more you can go to
rodine.isfeld yeah so a couple things
and one other point is this isn't just a
great place for people who want to buy
homes it's also a good place for people
who want to sell their home and maybe
move you know there's a fact that you
know there's not much churn happening in
the market right now fewer home owners
are selling their home to go buy
something new right now than we've seen
in 30 plus years and the reason is that
affordability is so cooked and they
don't want to give up their 2 3 4%
mortgage rate go get an 8% mortgage rate
so I think there's a lot of people who
would it would be good for them to read
resi Club because they might start to
understand you know when mortgage rates
might begin to move over roll over and
you know that helps with their
Lifestyles decision uh the other thing
is with the analytics you know we're
getting tons of data that we're scraping
in from Zillow from realor.com from
Freddy Mack uh you know a lot of these
big places and big names some real
estate data and a lot of this data is
out there and scrapable but the problem
is it isn't put into a format that's
actually readable and digestible and so
that's what we're doing with resic Club
in particular for the people who upgrade
to resi Club Pro where we're going to
have analytics for inventory and prices
not just at a Metro level not just at a
county level but down to a zip code
level and we're going to have the things
uh like the stuff that you know helps to
figure out the
um absorption rates by market because
the problem is the months of Supply just
isn't as strong of a metric as the
industry thinks in a period where
affordability has deteriorated this fast
and to this degree and so we have some
special sauce metrics that we think help
to read this particular environment and
then the other thing is we have a lot of
access to Executives in the real real
estate space and one reason that we do
for a publication that's only two weeks
old is they are interested in our data
they're interested in what we're hearing
they want to know what we're hearing
from other Executives because the TR the
truth here is this is one of the most
uncertain environments for housing that
we've been in in 15 years um you know
Executives in this space have watched us
take so many quick
180s uh that they are in a p you know in
a mindset where they're trying to figure
out what's going on they want to know uh
what other people think across the
country in the industry um and so I I
think resi Club is well positioned for
this uncertain environment and this
environment where housing data just
can't be read in traditional ways and I
think we're stepping up to the plate uh
with ways to actually read the data and
you know get the best insights in a
period That's So uncertain and with such
deteriorated
affordability I completely agree uh I'm
super excited about this and and uh
already I think the response that we've
seen from people speaks to just how much
demand there is for this information um
you've been doing a fantastic job if
anyone would like uh they can subscribe
you can just go to resi Club reesi Club
analytics.com um and uh you can
subscribe there uh there are five pieces
of uh content that go out every single
week uh completely for free and then if
you want you can subscribe as well um
and there's a bunch of exclusive
interviews and kind of Premium content
uh as well so uh resi Club analytics.com
is where you can go do that Lance maybe
I I'll leave you with the last word here
in terms of um does it get worse before
it gets better you know I think that's
really what people want to understand is
just like how do you look at uh if
somebody sitting there and they're
trying to figure out should I sell
should I not what what do I do like what
what is that framework maybe that you'd
walk them through through in terms of
trying to make personal decisions on uh
you know what what housing is going to
do and how it could affect them yeah so
last year mortgage rates moved up to 7%
prices gave just a little bit nationally
and I think there was a feeling that
okay we've seen the worst of the
affordability and then we came into this
year and National prices moved up more
we set a new uh all-time high this
summer and then rates went even higher
to 8% so as we are doing this call right
now this is the worst affordability and
like 35 years and um and so I would love
to sit here and say that you know the
worst is over and you know it you know
it's all you know a slow grind to
improvement from here on out we don't we
can't say that with certainty especially
the way the bond market has been acting
with this recent selloff that's pushed
up yields and pushed up mortgage rates
uh but I think what I can tell you is
that resi club's going to be all over it
whatever does begin to happen whatever
Trends start to manifest and the trends
that are already manifesting we're going
to be covering it and all the
subscribers will be getting details
every single day through through the
weekday Lance I appreciate it very much
uh you're going to be on here much more
often now um and we'll be covering uh
kind of the housing on affordability
mortgage rates and much much more so uh
anyone who is not following you on
Twitter news Lampert is uh a great place
to go subscribe to resi club and we'll
definitely do this again in the future
okay thanks Anthony